ha sido un pronunciamiento muy esperado
no ha empezado autodefiniéndose un joven
de 76 años y todo su discurso ha girado
alrededor de la palabra soberanía él ha
prometido recuperar la soberanía de
brasil en varios ámbitos económico
diplomático y lo ha hecho para casi
respondiendo al actual presidente jair
bolsonaro que en su momento usó esta
palabra para defender su gobierno otra
palabra muy repetida por el futuro
candidato es la actual candidato en la
palabra amor porque él se va a casar
este mes con su novia yania y él ha
dicho al final de su discurso que si un
hombre lleno de amor como él está
dispuesto a casarse de nuevo solo va a
ser el bien para el país él también ha
recordado que ha estado en la cárcel es
580 días ha hablado de una persecución
inicial y de hecho hace poco la onu ha
reconocido que el proceso del juicio no
fue correcto pero él ha jurado que no
está lleno de resentimiento y que va a
gobernar de nuevo con la palabra amor ha
recordado varios temas el tema del
hambre que aqueja a más de 19 millones
de brasileños ha recordado que va a
recuperar petrobras a la empresa
petrolífera más importante de brasil que
se va a poner a la privatización de
electrobrás que es la principal empresa
eléctrica y en definitiva ha prometido
recuperar a la economía de brasil pero
sobre todo el lugar internacional que
tuvo cuando él era presidente también ha
habido un discurso muy autorreferente
recordando sus antiguos éxitos cuando
fue presidente durante 8 años y ha
prometido que hará más de lo que hizo en
su primer y segundo mandato
valeria en las encuestas la ventaja de
lula sobre el actual mandatario yair
bolsonaro ha ido aumentando
recientemente como se prevé el panorama
para octubre el mes de los comicios
quedan casi cinco meses y brasil es
famoso por ser un país totalmente
imprevisible es verdad que
bolsonaro lentamente empieza a remontar
y también que tenemos muchas encuestas y
los datos cambian está claro que lula de
momento es el claro favorito y también
el hecho de tener un vice moderado que
puede hablar con el agronegocio que
puede hablar con los sectores más
ligados a la religión evangélica podría
aportarle más votos también hay más de 2
millones de jóvenes que han
conseguido el título de elector y que
probablemente van a votar por primera
vez por un cambio no se sabe habrá que
verlo en octubre lo que sí sabemos es
que brasil es un país imprevisible y que
de aquí al mes de octubre al 2 de
octubre puede pasar de todo